bien
[Música]
cientos de familiares y amigos de los
presos de san quintín piden a las
autoridades de california que una
condena no se convierta en una ejecución
ana teme por la vida de su hijo steven
quien le cuenta por teléfono lo que
ocurre en la prisión
perdí el sentido del gusto me dolía la
cabeza y los huesos no podía respirar
bien
pero no dije nada porque tenía miedo de
que hicieran lo que hacen con los
enfermos meternos en un agujero solos
anna asegura que a raíz de la pandemia
los presos no reciben la nutrición ni el
servicio médico adecuado
a veces les dan solo pan y queso a veces
hay moho en el pan entonces él no se lo
come solo están atendiendo las
emergencias ahora a gente con fiebre
alta solo por síntomas leves no les van
a llevar a que vean o hablen con el
médico incluso así es por teléfono no en
persona
el marido de catherine de jong comparte
espacio con el hijo de anna en el
gimnasio de la prisión donde cientos de
presos se hacinan a poca distancia por
tándem gimnasio volvieron a poner a
ciento y pico de personas todos juntos
a las gamas solo están separadas tres
pies de aparte no hay tantas distancias
sociales como el sitio y lo requieren
fillón es uno de los 150 presos que ha
iniciado una demanda exigiendo al
gobierno que les libere ya dará vida me
asesora a los abogados que llevan la
demanda
la oficina de las cárceles movió 100 22
hombres de una cárcel en un lugar que se
llama chino a la cárcel desencuentro y
no los aprobaron para acudir antes que
sacarlos de la cárcel el argumento
principal de esta demanda colectiva es
que hubo en negligencia y malicia por
parte de la prisión y el condado así
como en el trato que reciben ahora todos
los presos de la casa
[Aplausos]